you both have children we do have babies
that like eight months apart I learned
so much about being a parent from G no
really did I not text you a thousand
times say what would you do in this
situation when I came to your house I
can't get my baby to stop crying like
how do we do this how do I put him down
for a nap and I don't even know what I
remember what I say though you gave you
gave pretty good advice so
so I was holding it for eight hours a
day for his naps then Gigi was like okay
I'm gonna give you a tip this is how you
ease out a bit she was like put him in
the stroller he can still see you and
walk around your Island in your house
yeah and then put the island put the
stroller there and just kind of sit next
to it
you see he can still see you and then
he'll gradually fall asleep that advice
changed my life
thank you thank you
so much